Here is the complete, highly accurate, professional English translation of the entire transcript:
Hi, this is Edip Yuksel, 19.org.
I have some documents and some video recordings of Dr. Rashad Khalifa.
Uh, they have been with me for about 30 years, some of them 26 years after his assassination.
Now, you will be listening to his perhaps first announcement of 19, his discovery of Code 19 in 1974.
This video cassette on it with his own handwriting, it is written Radio Tripoli, Libya, 1974.
Year 1974 is written on it.
It is exactly the year of the discovery of Code 19, uh, which was secret in chapter named secret, The Hidden One.
Al-Muddathir means the secret chapter 74.
19 was hidden in chapter 74 for 19 times 74 lunar years after the revelation of the Quran.
And it was discovered in 1974 by Rashad Khalifa, whose name Rashad, the the all the derivatives of Rashad is mentioned in the Quran is exactly 19 times.
code of the Quran, which was also discovered in some old original portion of the Old Testament by Rabbi Judah in 11th century.
Okay, I want to leave you with this Rashad Khalifa's things.
Again, Rashad Khalifa discovered this 19 in 1974.
1974 lunar years after revelation of the Quran in year 1974, which is the numerical value of 19 letters of the first statement of this chapter.
يَا أَيُّهَا الْمُدَّثِّرُ قُمْ فَأَنذِرْ [Quran 74:1-2]
Oh, the hidden one, come out and warn.
It has 19 letters and the numerical value of these letters, which was used during time of Muhammad until two centuries after Muhammad, the geometrical values were used for numbers.
It is exactly 1974.
Okay, enjoy.
Okay, let's push.
In the beginning, there is recitation of the Quran and some music.
Maybe one or two minutes.
No, maybe one minute.
This is again Radio Tripoli, year 1974.
Dr. Rashad Khalifa is
القرآن الكريم والحديث من الجمهوريه العربيه الليبيه
The Holy Quran and Hadith from the Libyan Arab Republic.
declaring Code 19, his discovery in 1974.
The biggest historical event, I believe, in the
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
regarding philosophy and theology.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
صدق الله العظيم
God Almighty has spoken the truth.
The greatest evidence belongs to God.
God has the greatest evidence, truth, and he guides.
And he is the one who guides.
He recited a verse.
Again, this is an old cassette, audio cassette.
Rashad's handwriting on it, written 1974 in Arabic, Radio Tripoli, Libya.
الاعجاز القراني
The Quranic Miracle.
Al-I'jaz al-Qur'ani means the Quranic miracle.
الاعجاز القراني
The Quranic Miracle.
برنامج من اذاعه القران الكريم والحديث
A program from the Holy Quran and Hadith Radio
بالجمهوريه العربيه الليبيه
of the Libyan Arab Republic,
يعده ويقدمه
prepared and presented by
الدكتور رشاد خليفه
Dr. Rashad Khalifa.
Rashad was Sunni that time.
Within few years, he rejects Hadith and Sunnah and in 1980, he published a book.
الحمد لله رب العالمين
All praise is due to God, Lord of the worlds,
والصلاه والسلام على خاتم النبيين سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
and prayers and peace be upon the Seal of the Prophets, our master Muhammad, and upon his family and all his companions.
Later he did not, he rejected this.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
Peace, mercy, and blessings of God be upon you.
من دراستنا لمعجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في الحلقه السابقه
From our study of the miracle of "Bismillah Al-Rahman Al-Rahim" in the previous episode,
علمنا ان قارئ القران الكريم قبل ان يخطو خطوه واحده من خطوات رحلته تجاه رساله الله
we learned that the reader of the Holy Quran, before taking a single step in his journey towards God's message,
تقابله معجزه باهره تحمل في طياتها الدليل المادي الملموس
is met with a dazzling miracle that carries within it tangible, material proof
ان هذا القران لا يمكن ان يكون من صنع البشر
that this Quran cannot be man-made,
وانه بحق رساله خالقه اليه ووسيله خلاصه وطريق سعادته في الدنيا والاخره
and that it is truly a message from his Creator to him, a means of his salvation, and the path to his happiness in this world and the Hereafter.
هذه المعجزه الواجده في بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
This miracle found in "Bismillah Al-Rahman Al-Rahim"
هي ان هذه الايه الاولى في القران الكريم تتركب من 19 حرفا
is that this first verse in the Holy Quran consists of 19 letters,
وكل كلمه من كلمات هذه الايه تتكرر في المصحف الشريف كله عددا من المرات
and every word of this verse is repeated throughout the entire Holy Quran a number of times
هو دائما من مقررات العدد 19
that is always a multiple of 19.
فكلمه اسم تتكرر في القران العظيم 19 مره
So the word "Ism" (Name) is repeated in the Glorious Quran 19 times.
ولفظ الجلاله الله يتكرر 2698
And the majestic word "Allah" (God) is repeated 2698
والرقم 19 مكررا 142 مره
times, and the number 19 is repeated 142 times.
وكلمه الرحمن تتكرر في القران الكريم 57 مره
And the word "Al-Rahman" (The Most Gracious) is repeated in the Holy Quran 57 times,
57 times
اي الرقم 19 مكررا ثلاث مرات
meaning the number 19 repeated three times.
وكلمه الرحيم تتكرر 114 مره اي 19 مكرره ست مرات
And the word "Al-Rahim" (The Most Merciful) is repeated 114 times, meaning 19 repeated six times.
وبدراسه جميع الاحتمالات الممكن استنتاجها من هذه الحقائق الاعجازيه القرانيه
By studying all possible conclusions from these miraculous Quranic facts,
خلصنا الى ان الاحتمال الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يقبله اي شخص عاقل
we concluded that the only possibility that any rational person can accept
هو ان الله سبحانه وتعالى هو بحق منزل القران بما فيه من تصميم واحكام
is that God Almighty is truly the Revealer of the Quran, with its design and precision,
وتطابق طاقات الانس والجن
and the congruence of the energies of humans and jinn.
فنحن عندما نتفكر في هذه الحقائق نجد ان كلمات القران الكريم
So when we reflect on these facts, we find that the words of the Holy Quran
قد وضعت طبقا لتصميم حسابي وان القران كتاب احكمت اياته
have been placed according to a mathematical design, and that the Quran is a book whose verses have been perfected,
ثم فصلت من لدن حكيم خبير
then expounded from One All-Wise, All-Aware.
احكمت اياته اي وضعت باحكام وتدقيق وتصنيف
"Its verses have been perfected" means they were placed with precision, accuracy, and classification.
فنحن عندما نقول قل هو الله احد
So when we say, "Say, He is God, the One,"
نعلم الان ان كلمه الله هنا معدوده ومحسوبه اي موضوعه باحكام
we now know that the word "Allah" here is counted and calculated, meaning it is placed with precision.
فكلمة الله هنا واحده من 2698 المذكوره في القران كله
So the word "Allah" here is one of the 2698 mentioned in the entire Quran,
وهو كما ذكرت من مقررات الرقم 19 عدد حروف البسمله
and as I mentioned, it is a multiple of the number 19, the number of letters in the Basmalah.
وعندما نقول الله الصمد كلمه الله هنا ايضا معدوده ومحسوبه
And when we say, "Allah, the Eternal Refuge," the word "Allah" here is also counted and calculated.
كما اننا اذا نظرنا الى اخر ايه نزلت وهي باتفاق غالبيه الفقهاء
Furthermore, if we look at the last verse revealed, which by agreement of the majority of jurists
واتقوا يوما ترجعون فيه الى الله ثم توفى كل نفس ما كسبت وهم لا يظلمون
is: "And fear a Day when you will be returned to God. Then every soul will be compensated for what it earned, and they will not be wronged."
كلمة الله في هذه الايه اتمت العدد الذي شاءه الله سبحانه وتعالى
The word "Allah" in this verse completed the number that God Almighty willed,
طبقا لاحكامه وتصميمه بحيث كانت كلمه الله في هذه الايه الاخيره
according to His precision and design, such that the word "Allah" in this last verse
متممه للعدد 2698
completed the count of 2698.
واذا نظرنا الى كلمه الرحيم التي تتكرر في القران الكريم 114 مره
And if we look at the word "Al-Rahim" (The Most Merciful), which is repeated in the Holy Quran 114 times –
عدد سور القران الكريم واحد مقررات الرقم 19
the number of chapters in the Holy Quran and a multiple of 19 –
يتبين لنا وجه جديد من اوجه الاعجاز وهو وجه الحفاظ على القران الكريم
a new aspect of the miracle becomes clear to us, which is the aspect of preserving the Holy Quran
وحمايته التامه من اي تحريف
and its complete protection from any distortion.
ويكمن الاعجاز هنا في ان الذين نقلوا الينا هذا الكتاب الضخم
The miracle here lies in the fact that those who transmitted this massive book to us
لم يكونوا اناسا طالعين في علوم المكتبات والتوثيق
were not people versed in library sciences and documentation,
ولم يكونوا من خبراء البحث العلمي بل كانوا من بدو الصحراء
nor were they experts in scientific research; rather, they were desert Bedouins
الذين انقطعت صلتهم بالحضارات والعلوم
whose connection to civilizations and sciences had been severed.
ولكي نستوضح هذا الوجه من وجوه الاعجاز فلننظر الى الايه 218 من سوره البقره
To clarify this aspect of the miracle, let us look at verse 218 of Surah Al-Baqarah.
هذه الايه تقول
This verse says:
إِنَّ الَّذِينَ آمَنُوا وَالَّذِينَ هَاجَرُوا وَجَاهَدُوا فِي سَبِيلِ اللَّهِ أُولَٰئِكَ يَرْجُونَ رَحْمَتَ اللَّهِ ۚ وَاللَّهُ غَفُورٌ رَّحِيمٌ [Quran 2:218]
Indeed, those who have believed and those who have emigrated and striven in the cause of God – those expect the mercy of God. And God is Forgiving and Merciful.
كلمة رحيم هنا واحده من 114 التي وضعت باحكام الهي
The word "Rahim" (Merciful) here is one of the 114 that was placed with divine precision,
شانها في ذلك كما سنرى ان شاء الله شان كل كلمه بل كل حرف من حروف القران العظيم
just as, God willing, every word, indeed every letter, of the Glorious Quran.
ثم دعنا ننظر بعد ذلك الى الايه 225 من نفس السوره
Then let us look at verse 225 of the same Surah.
هذه تقول
This says:
لَا يُؤَاخِذُكُمُ اللَّهُ بِاللَّغْوِ فِي أَيْمَانِكُمْ وَلَٰكِن يُؤَاخِذُكُم بِمَا كَسَبَتْ قُلُوبُكُمْ ۗ وَاللَّهُ غَفُورٌ حَلِيمٌ [Quran 2:225]
God will not impose blame upon you for what is unintentional in your oaths, but He will impose blame upon you for what your hearts have earned. And God is Forgiving and Forbearing.
نعلم الان من معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ان كلمة حليم في هذه الايه
We now know from the miracle of "Bismillah Al-Rahman Al-Rahim" that the word "Halim" (Forbearing) in this verse
لم توضع صدفه او اعتباطا او عشوائيه
was not placed by chance, arbitrarily, or randomly.
ونرى كيف ان بدو الصحراء الذين عاشوا في القرن السابع الميلادي
And we see how the desert Bedouins who lived in the seventh century AD
قد نقلوا الينا كتاب الله بامانه يعجز عنها علماء القرن العشرين
transmitted to us the Book of God with a trustworthiness that twentieth-century scientists are incapable of.
فمن السهل ان يخلط الانسان بين غفور رحيم وغفور حليم
For it is easy for a person to confuse "Ghafur Rahim" (Forgiving, Merciful) and "Ghafur Halim" (Forgiving, Forbearing),
خاصه وان هذه كلها اسماء الله الحسنى
especially since all of these are among God's Most Beautiful Names.
ولكن الضمان الالهي
But the divine guarantee:
إِنَّا نَحْنُ نَزَّلْنَا الذِّكْرَ وَإِنَّا لَهُ لَحَافِظُونَ [Quran 15:9]
Indeed, We have sent down the Reminder, and indeed, We will be its guardian.
تكفل بالمحافظه على كل حرف في رساله الله الختاميه حتى تبقى معجزه ابديه
ensured the preservation of every letter in God's final message, so that it remains an eternal miracle,
لا حاجه بعدها الى اضافات او تعديلات
with no need for additions or alterations thereafter.
وبين ايدينا من خلال هذه الحقائق الحسابيه الدليل المادي الملموس
And before us, through these mathematical facts, is the tangible, material proof
ان القران الكريم قد وصل الينا محكما كاملا
that the Holy Quran has reached us perfectly preserved and complete.
وسنرى في الحلقات التاليه ان شاء الله ان القران الكريم
And we will see in the following episodes, God willing, that the Holy Quran
ليس فقط محكم الكلمات بل ان الحروف الابجديه نزلت باحكام دقيق
is not only precise in its words, but that the alphabetical letters were revealed with precise regulation
وتصميم حسابي معجز
and a miraculous mathematical design.
ما هو دليلنا ان معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لها علاقه بكون القران الكريم من صنع الله عز وجل
What is our proof that the miracle of "Bismillah Al-Rahman Al-Rahim" is related to the Holy Quran being from God Almighty,
وانه لا يمكن ان يكون من صنع البشر
and that it cannot be man-made?
ان الاجابه على هذا السؤال الهام تقع في سوره المدثر
The answer to this important question lies in Surah Al-Muddathir.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
ذَرْنِي وَمَنْ خَلَقْتُ وَحِيدًا [Quran 74:11]
Leave Me and him whom I created alone.
وَجَعَلْتُ لَهُ مَالًا مَّمْدُودًا [Quran 74:12]
And to whom I granted extensive wealth.
وَبَنِينَ شُهُودًا [Quran 74:13]
And sons present [with him].
وَمَهَّدتُّ لَهُ تَمْهِيدًا [Quran 74:14]
And I smoothed for him [the way] with smooth accommodation.
ثُمَّ يَطْمَعُ أَنْ أَزِيدَ [Quran 74:15]
Then he desires that I add more.
كَلَّا ۖ إِنَّهُ كَانَ لِآيَاتِنَا عَنِيدًا [Quran 74:16]
No! Indeed, he has been to Our verses an obstinate opponent.
سَأُرْهِقُهُ صَعُودًا [Quran 74:17]
I will burden him with a [difficult] ascent.
إِنَّهُ فَكَّرَ وَقَدَّرَ [Quran 74:18]
Indeed, he thought and deliberated.
فَقُتِلَ كَيْفَ قَدَّرَ [Quran 74:19]
So may he be destroyed – how he deliberated!
ثُمَّ قُتِلَ كَيْفَ قَدَّرَ [Quran 74:20]
Then may he be destroyed – how he deliberated!
ثُمَّ نَظَرَ [Quran 74:21]
Then he looked.
ثُمَّ عَبَسَ وَبَسَرَ [Quran 74:22]
Then he frowned and scowled.
ثُمَّ أَدْبَرَ وَاسْتَكْبَرَ [Quran 74:23]
Then he turned away and was arrogant.
فَقَالَ إِنْ هَٰذَا إِلَّا سِحْرٌ يُؤْثَرُ [Quran 74:24]
And said, "This is not but magic [transmitted] from old times."
إِنْ هَٰذَا إِلَّا قَوْلُ الْبَشَرِ [Quran 74:25]
"This is not but the word of a human being."
سَأُصْلِيهِ سَقَرَ [Quran 74:26]
I will cast him into Saqar.
وَمَا أَدْرَاكَ مَا سَقَرُ [Quran 74:27]
And what can make you know what Saqar is?
لَا تُبْقِي وَلَا تَذَرُ [Quran 74:28]
It leaves nothing [unburned] and spares nothing.
لَوَّاحَةٌ لِّلْبَشَرِ [Quran 74:29]
It scorches the skin.
عَلَيْهَا تِسْعَةَ عَشَرَ [Quran 74:30]
Over it are nineteen.
صدق الله العظيم
God Almighty has spoken the truth.
فنحن نرى من هذه الايات الكريمه ان الانسان الذي يقرر ان القران الكريم من قول البشر
So we see from these noble verses that the person who decides that the Holy Quran is the word of humans,
سيسلط الله عليه 19
God will unleash upon him the 19.
وفي ضوء ما نعلمه اليوم من معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
And in light of what we know today from the miracle of "Bismillah Al-Rahman Al-Rahim,"
فان هذه ال 19 هي حروف الايه الاولى في القران الكريم وهي بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
these 19 are the letters of the first verse in the Holy Quran, which is "Bismillah Al-Rahman Al-Rahim,"
والتي تحمل في طياتها الدليل الدامغ على ان القران الكريم لا يمكن ان يكون من قول البشر
and which carries within it conclusive proof that the Holy Quran cannot be the word of humans.
ويتحتم ان ننوه هنا بالتفسيرات القديمه التي قالت ان ال 19 هنا ملائكه يحرسون النار
And it is imperative to note here the old interpretations that said the 19 here are angels guarding Hellfire.
وبني هذا التفسير على اساس الايه التاليه لايه عليها 19
And this interpretation was built on the basis of the verse following "Over it are nineteen,"
حيث تقول
where it says:
وَمَا جَعَلْنَا أَصْحَابَ النَّارِ إِلَّا مَلَائِكَةً ۙ وَمَا جَعَلْنَا عِدَّتَهُمْ إِلَّا فِتْنَةً لِّلَّذِينَ كَفَرُوا لِيَسْتَيْقِنَ الَّذِينَ أُوتُوا الْكِتَابَ وَيَزْدَادَ الَّذِينَ آمَنُوا إِيمَانًا ۙ وَلَا يَرْتَابَ الَّذِينَ أُوتُوا الْكِتَابَ وَالْمُؤْمِنُونَ ۙ وَلِيَقُولَ الَّذِينَ فِي قُلُوبِهِم مَّرَضٌ وَالْكَافِرُونَ مَاذَا أَرَادَ اللَّهُ بِهَٰذَا مَثَلًا ۚ كَذَٰلِكَ يُضِلُّ اللَّهُ مَن يَشَاءُ وَيَهْدِي مَن يَشَاءُ ۚ وَمَا يَعْلَمُ جُنُودَ رَبِّكَ إِلَّا هُوَ ۚ وَمَا هِيَ إِلَّا ذِكْرَىٰ لِلْبَشَرِ [Quran 74:31]
And We have not made the guardians of the Fire except angels, and We have not made their number except as a trial for those who disbelieve – that those who were given the Scripture will be convinced and those who have believed will increase in faith, and that those who were given the Scripture and the believers will not doubt, and that those in whose hearts is hypocrisy and the disbelievers will say, "What did God intend by this as an example?" Thus does God leave astray whom He wills and guides whom He wills. And none knows the soldiers of your Lord except Him. And it is not but a reminder to humanity.
صدق الله العظيم
God Almighty has spoken the truth.
تبدا الايه بالقول وما جعلنا اصحاب النار الا ملائكه
The verse begins by saying, "And We have not made the guardians of the Fire except angels,"
وهو تعبير يوحي بان عليها 19 ربما تعني ان حراس النار هم 19 من الملائكه
which is an expression that suggests that "Over it are nineteen" might mean that the guardians of Hellfire are 19 angels.
وكان هذا هو مصدر التفسير القديم الذي كان مناسبا للاجيال السابقه والتي لم يشاء الله سبحانه وتعالى
And this was the source of the old interpretation, which was suitable for previous generations whom God Almighty did not wish
ان يطلعهم على معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
to inform about the miracle of "Bismillah Al-Rahman Al-Rahim."
الا ان بدايه الايه وما جعلنا اصحاب النار الا ملائكه لا تحمل الاختبار
However, the beginning of the verse, "And We have not made the guardians of the Fire except angels," does not carry the test
او الالتزام بان ال 19 هم حراس النار
or the commitment that the 19 are the guardians of Hellfire.
وباستمرارنا في تلاوه الايه نجد انها تقول
And by continuing to recite the verse, we find that it says,
وما جعلنا عدتهم الا اي ما جعلنا هذا العدد 19
"And We have not made their number except..." meaning, We did not make this number 19,
وما اخترناه الا للاسباب التاليه
and We did not choose it except for the following reasons:
اولا فتنه للذين كفروا اي ازعاجا واخلاقا للذين كفروا
Firstly, "as a trial for those who disbelieve," meaning a disturbance and a moral challenge for those who disbelieve,
واثباتا وتركيزا لكفرهم
and a confirmation and reinforcement of their disbelief.
ثانيا ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب
Secondly, "that those who were given the Scripture will be convinced."
فهناك من اهل الكتاب من يتساءل هل القران صحيح منزل من عند الله
For there are some among the People of the Book who wonder, "Is the Quran truly revealed from God?"
فالعدد 19 هنا جاء بما فيه من معاني ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب
So the number 19 here came with its meanings so that those who were given the Scripture would be convinced,
ليعلموا ويتاكدوا ويستيقنوا ان هذا القران الكريم
to know, to be certain, and to be convinced that this Holy Quran
جاء بالفعل من عند ربنا وربهم من عند الله الواحد القهار
indeed came from our Lord and their Lord, from God, the One, the Subduer.
ثالثا ويزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا اي اننا نحن المؤمنون
Thirdly, "and those who have believed will increase in faith," meaning that we, the believers,
بان هذا القران هو كتاب من عند الله يزداد ايماننا عن طريق ال 19
who believe that this Quran is a book from God, our faith increases through the 19.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
عليها 19
Over it are nineteen.
وما جعلنا اصحاب النار الا ملائكه وما جعلنا عدتهم الا فتنه للذين كفروا
"And We have not made the guardians of the Fire except angels, and We have not made their number except as a trial for those who disbelieve –
ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب ويزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا
that those who were given the Scripture will be convinced and those who have believed will increase in faith."
ويحضرني هنا ما يساله بعض الناس هل نحن في حاجه الى هذه البراهين والدلائل
And it comes to my mind here what some people ask: "Are we in need of all these proofs and evidences?"
وسنجيب ان شاء الله على هذا السؤال ونستكمل هذه الحلقه
And we will answer this question, God willing, and complete this episode
في المره القادمه ان شاء الله والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
next time, God willing. And peace, mercy, and blessings of God be upon you.
I'm not sure after this one whether we have more recording because first time I'm listening.
I don't want to risk the cassette since it is an old one.
Let me check.
I'm going to pause here.
الاعجاز القراني
The Quranic Miracle.
اذاعه القران الكريم والحديث من الجمهوريه العربيه الليبيه
The Holy Quran and Hadith Radio of the Libyan Arab Republic.
اخوه الايمان في ختام فتره ارسال اذاعه القران الكريم والحديث
Brothers and sisters in faith, at the conclusion of the broadcast period of the Holy Quran and Hadith Radio,
نستمع خاشعين الى ما يتيسر من سوره الاعراف من تسجيلات المرحوم
we listen with reverence to what is available from Surah Al-A'raf from the recordings of the late
الشيخ كامل يوسف البهتيمي
Sheikh Kamel Youssef Al-Bahtimi.
There is Quranic recitation following up.
I will stop recording after few verses.
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
I seek refuge in God from Satan, the rejected.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
فلو شاء لهداكم اجمعين
And if He had willed, He would have guided you all.
صدق الله العظيم
God Almighty has spoken the truth.
I really don't know whether there is more coming from Rashad Khalifa.
I'm waiting like you do.
First time I'm listening after 26 years from my having this cassette since 1974.
الاعجاز القراني
The Quranic Miracle.
I hope this is the second session of Dr. Rashad Khalifa's announcement of Code 19, his discovery.
In previous section, he summarized about the frequency of the words in Basmalah.
الاعجاز القراني برنامج من اذاعه القران الكريم والحديث بالجمهوريه العربيه الليبيه
The Quranic Miracle, a program from the Holy Quran and Hadith Radio of the Libyan Arab Republic,
يعده ويقدمه الدكتور رشاد خليفه
prepared and presented by Dr. Rashad Khalifa.
Oh, hopefully this is the second session.
Unfortunately, they add Hadith, the satanic teachings to the Quran.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
الحمد لله رب العالمين
All praise is due to God, Lord of the worlds,
والصلاه والسلام على خاتم النبيين سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
and prayers and peace be upon the Seal of the Prophets, our master Muhammad, and upon his family and all his companions.
As you hear Dr. Khalifa that time, he was still influenced by Sunni teaching.
They distort the verses, uh,
إِنَّ اللَّهَ وَمَلَائِكَتَهُ يُصَلُّونَ عَلَى النَّبِيِّ [Quran 33:56]
Indeed, God and His angels send blessings upon the Prophet.
that verse, they distort the meaning of salla.
They say you must say, qul, and then some words.
In fact, it is about supporting, uh, prophet, the leader while he was alive.
God and his angels support the prophet.
Oh, believer, you support him too.
But similar two verses also there is that tells Muhammad,
خُذْ مِنْ أَمْوَالِهِمْ صَدَقَةً تُطَهِّرُهُمْ وَتُزَكِّيهِم بِهَا وَصَلِّ عَلَيْهِمْ ۖ إِنَّ صَلَاتَكَ سَكَنٌ لَّهُمْ [Quran 9:103]
Take, [O Muhammad], from their wealth a charity by which you purify them and cause them increase, and invoke [God's blessings] upon them. Indeed, your invocations are reassurance for them.
tells Muhammad to salli 'ala them.
I use the same word so that you hear it, to support them.
Therefore, the word salli 'ala is not something to be uttered but to be done, not only to Muhammad, also Muhammad had to do to believers around, to believers I say, well, to those who who trust in God or the peacemakers around him.
And also we see another verse, there are three verses about salli 'ala,
هُوَ الَّذِي يُصَلِّي عَلَيْكُمْ وَمَلَائِكَتُهُ لِيُخْرِجَكُم مِّنَ الظُّلُمَاتِ إِلَى النُّورِ [Quran 33:43]
It is He who confers blessing upon you, and His angels [ask Him to do so] that He may bring you out from darknesses into the light.
God and his angels, the controllers, um, supports you.
Uh, supports you to to basically take you out of darkness to enlighten you.
And again, we see it that salli 'ala is not exclusive for Muhammad, is also for all those who are righteous, who are peacemakers, who are monotheist.
And God and his angels, they do salat to them too.
Therefore, uh, the Sunni Shiite clergyman, later they distorted the meaning of salli 'ala as an exclusive prayer or praise for Muhammad.
Uh, I wanted to pull your attention to this one.
Rashad Khalifa in his landmark book, uh, landmark book Quran, Hadith and Islam, he exposes this distortion very well.
And that book, in fact, when I read it after several round of debate with him through snail mail, while I was in Turkey in 1986, um, in 1st July, I was able to receive from him.
He sent me the book after some heated debate.
I was defending Hadith.
I was sending him Hadith and he was sending me one verse with swallowing all the Hadith, all the snakes, like Moses' staff.
Each time he was responding with verses, I would respond with fabricated Hadith.
Hadith and yuftara.
And then I got confused and I couldn't leave Hadith altogether because, uh, I was my father was the very well-known, very influential Sunni scholar.
I was very heavily poisoned.
My understanding of verses was very different.
I thought obeying God and messenger, messenger means Bukhari's fabrications.
And then he asked me whether I had his book Quran, Hadith and Islam.
I said no.
I said, I said, I wrote, that time I was communicating through mail.
And then he sent me Quran, Hadith and Islam.
I read it in a couple of hours.
It is very easy read book and, oh my God, it was unbelievable.
It changed my life and that night was the night of power, Laylatul Qadr, my Laylatul Qadr.
That time the Quran revealed to me.
Initially that the Quran was ambiguous, that I couldn't understand, that I thought it needs volumes, volumes of contradictory Hadith books.
Again, undefined volumes.
There are six volumes and they have also different classification of Hadith.
And besides that, there are other Hadith and also the teachings of sectarian fatwas and all those books, really you don't know what is what.
Ask the followers of Hadith and Sunnah, how many really authentic Hadith you have?
They will never be able to come up with the Hadith.
They, they have 31 classification, 31 classification of Hadith from Mawdu to Mutawatir.
Even their top, supposedly the most authentic Mutawatir Hadith, if you ask them their number, they will not come into an agreement regarding even their Mutawatir Hadith, the most authentic Hadith.
Ironically, the most authentic Hadith, according to them is the Hadith about not writing anything besides the Quran from Muhammad.
لا تكتبوا عني شيئا سوى القران فمن يكتب فليمحوه
Do not write anything from me except the Quran. Whoever writes anything else, let him erase it.
there is that Hadith.
And this is supposedly a Mutawatir means it is narrated by very multiple chains, so many chains that it is impossible to doubt its authenticity.
But this very Mutawatir Hadith, according to their own claim, is trashed by an Ahad, one single Hadith made up later and they trash this Hadith.
So contradictory.
Anyway, I put a long parenthesis about Rashad's utterance, the Mushriks, Sunni Mushriks distortion about Muhammad.
They praise God, they cannot praise God alone.
They always need an urge to add Muhammad's name.
Even in Azan, they'd added,
وَأَنَّ الْمَسَاجِدَ لِلَّهِ فَلَا تَدْعُوا مَعَ اللَّهِ أَحَدًا [Quran 72:18]
And that the mosques are for God, so do not invoke with God anyone.
Uh, the Masajid belongs to God alone, the temples, do not call anyone besides God.
But they add Muhammad's name and also La ilaha illallah throughout the Quran is only God mentioned when God's oneness is emphasized, no other name is juxtaposed, but they add Muhammad's name to it.
They violate, uh, 39:45, chapter 49, verse 45 and also 3:18, chapter 3, verse 18.
It is about Shahadat approved by God and angels and those who are endowed with knowledge.
And also their Shahada very interestingly is exposed as the Shahada of hypocrites in chapter 63, verse 1.
And also the archaeological evidence, the earliest coins, um, gold coins, gold and silver coins of Umayyad times, initially, you don't see Muhammad's name on it, only La ilaha illallah or Allahu Ahad, Allahu Samad or La ilaha illallah wahdahu la sharika lah.
And later generation, you see Muhammad's name add to the margin in circle through copy and paste, cut, copy and paste.
From the last verse of chapter Fatiha.
And then they later they put in the backside in the middle and then only in fourth stage, each takes about 10, 15, 20 years.
And then in last stage of coins, finally, the Satan is able through make them get familiar with Muhammad's name and then in the end put next to God in the middle.
Okay, let's listen.
ايها الاخوه والاخوات السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
O brothers and sisters, peace, mercy, and blessings of God be upon you.
حدثتكم في الحلقه السابقه عن علاقه معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بالايه القرانيه
In the previous episode, I spoke to you about the relationship of the miracle of "Bismillah Al-Rahman Al-Rahim" with the Quranic verse
عليها 19 وهي الايه رقم 30 من سوره المدثر
"Over it are nineteen," which is verse number 30 of Surah Al-Muddathir.
وراينا في ضوء هذه المعجزه القرانيه ان ال 19 المذكورين في هذه الايه
And we saw, in light of this Quranic miracle, that the 19 mentioned in this verse
هم على اغلب الظن ال 19 حرفا الذين تتكون منهم الايه الاولى في القران
are most likely the 19 letters that make up the first verse in the Quran,
وهي البسمله وان التفسير القديم بان ال 19 هم حراس النار
which is the Basmalah, and that the old interpretation that the 19 are the guardians of Hellfire
قد لا يكون تفسيرا صحيحا اذ ان الايه التاليه رقم 31 من سوره المدثر تقول
may not be a correct interpretation, as the following verse, number 31 of Surah Al-Muddathir, says:
وما جعلنا عدتهم الا فتنه للذين كفروا ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب
"And We have not made their number except as a trial for those who disbelieve – that those who were given the Scripture will be convinced."
ووقفنا في الحلقه السابقه عند السبب الثالث الذي من اجله اختار الله سبحانه وتعالى
And in the previous episode, we stopped at the third reason for which God Almighty chose
العدد 19 مسلطا اياه على كل من يقول بان القران من قول البشر
the number 19, imposing it upon everyone who says that the Quran is the word of humans.
هذا السبب الثالث كما تبين الايه هو
This third reason, as the verse shows, is:
ويزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا
"and those who have believed will increase in faith."
وهنا طرحت السؤال الذي يساله بعض الناس وهو
And here I posed the question that some people ask, which is:
هل نحن في حاجه الى كل هذه البراهين والدلائل على اعجاز القران
"Are we in need of all these proofs and evidences for the Quran's miraculousness?
اننا نؤمن ونصدق ان القران الكريم هو بحق من قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
We believe and affirm that the Holy Quran is truly the word of God Almighty.
لماذا تستخدمون الالات الحاسبه الالكترونيه او العقول الالكترونيه للبحث عن الاعجاز القراني
Why do you use electronic calculators or electronic minds to search for the Quranic miracle?"
ونحن نرى الاجابه على هذه الاسئله كلها في الايه 31 من سوره المدثر
And we see the answer to all these questions in verse 31 of Surah Al-Muddathir.
وما جعلنا عدتهم اي العدد 19 المذكور في الايه السابقه
"And We have not made their number" – meaning the number 19 mentioned in the previous verse –
وما جعلنا عدتهم الا فتنه للذين كفروا ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب
"And We have not made their number except as a trial for those who disbelieve – that those who were given the Scripture will be convinced
ويزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا
and those who have believed will increase in faith."
ولقد كان لنا اسوه حسنه في سيدنا الخليل ابراهيم عليه السلام
And we have a good example in our master, the intimate friend of God, Abraham, peace be upon him.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
واذ قال ابراهيم رب ارني كيف تحيي الموتى
And [mention] when Abraham said, "My Lord, show me how You give life to the dead."
قال اولم تؤمن قال بلى ولكن ليطمئن قلبي
He said, "Have you not believed?" He said, "Yes, but [I ask] only that my heart may be satisfied."
اين نحن من ابي الانبياء سيدنا ابراهيم ها هو يسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
Where are we compared to the father of the prophets, our master Abraham? Here he is asking God Almighty
ان يريه كيف يحيي الموتى ليطمئن قلبه ليزداد ايمانه
to show him how He gives life to the dead, so that his heart may be satisfied, so that his faith may increase.
ولم يغضب الله سبحانه وتعالى من هذا الطلب ولم يعلق رسوله ابراهيم عليه السلام بل قال له
And God Almighty was not angered by this request, nor did He rebuke His messenger Abraham, peace be upon him. Rather, He said to him:
خذ اربعه من الطير فصرهن اليك ثم اجعل على كل جبل منهن جزءا
"Take four birds and incline them to yourself. Then put on every mountain a portion of them;
ثم ادعهن ياتينك سعيا واعلم ان الله عزيز حكيم
then call them – they will come to you in haste. And know that God is Exalted in Might and Wise."
فاذا كانت هذه حال سيدنا ابراهيم عليه السلام الذي جعله الله للناس اماما
So if this was the state of our master Abraham, peace be upon him, whom God made an Imam for humanity,
فما احوجنا نحن الى ان نتدبر القران وان نبحث عما فيه من معجزات باهرات
then how much more do we need to ponder the Quran and search for its dazzling miracles,
ليزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا كما تقول هذه الايه الكريمه من سوره المدثر
so that "those who have believed will increase in faith," as this noble verse from Surah Al-Muddathir says.
السبب الرابع الذي من اجله اختار الله سبحانه وتعالى الرقم 19
The fourth reason for which God Almighty chose the number 19,
ليكون حجه على الذين يقولون بان القران من قول البشر
to be a proof against those who say that the Quran is the word of humans.
هذا السبب الرابع كما تعلمنا الايه
This fourth reason, as the verse teaches us, is:
ولا يرتاب الذين اوتوا الكتاب والمؤمنون
"and that those who were given the Scripture and the believers will not doubt."
اي لازاله الريبه والشكوك الذي قد تراود اهل الكتاب والمؤمنين
Meaning, to remove the doubt and suspicions that might occur to the People of the Book and the believers,
الحجه الالهيه الدامغه ان شاء الله
the conclusive divine proof, God willing.
النظريه الاولى في تفسير او شرح لدلاله الحروف النورانيه
The first theory in interpreting or explaining the significance of the luminous letters (Muqatta'at) –
واعتبرت هذه المحاوله محاوله دراسه العلاقه بين الحروف النورانيه
this attempt, an attempt to study the relationship between the luminous letters
واسماء الله الحسنى المذكوره في السور في فواتح السور محاوله فاشله
and the Beautiful Names of God mentioned in the opening of the chapters, was considered a failed attempt
لا تستطيع ان تفسر لنا دلالات ومعاني الحروف النورانيه
that could not explain to us the significances and meanings of the luminous letters.
وانتقلت الدراسه بعد ذلك الى العلاقه بين حروف النورانيه واسماء الرسل والانبياء المذكورين في السور التي افتتحوا بهذه الحروف
The study then moved to the relationship between the luminous letters and the names of the messengers and prophets mentioned in the chapters that open with these letters.
يعني مثلا في سوره مريم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
For example, in Surah Maryam, "In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
كاف ها يا عين صاد ذكر رحمه ربك عبده زكريا
Kaf Ha Ya Ain Sad. [This is] a mention of the mercy of your Lord to His servant Zechariah."
هل الحرف الكاف في كاف ها يا عين صاد يرمز الى سيدنا زكريا عليه السلام
Does the letter Kaf in Kaf Ha Ya Ain Sad symbolize our master Zechariah, peace be upon him?
وكان مصير هذه المحاوله الفشل كما فشلت المحاوله السابقه لها
And the fate of this attempt was failure, just as the previous attempt failed.
وهكذا استمرت محاولات فهم دلالات الحروف النورانيه وتكرر الفشل
Thus, attempts to understand the significances of the luminous letters continued, and failure was repeated.
واخيرا وفقني الله سبحانه وتعالى الى دراسه العلاقه بين الحروف النورانيه
Finally, God Almighty guided me to study the relationship between the luminous letters
ونظام توزيع هذه الحروف في جميع سور القران الكريم
and the system of distribution of these letters in all chapters of the Holy Quran.
واثبت ان القران الكريم نزل من عند الخالق عز وجل الى الحبيب المصطفى صلى الله عليه وسلم
And I proved that the Holy Quran was revealed from the Creator, Exalted and Glorified, to the Beloved Chosen One, peace and blessings be upon him,
عن طريق الروح الامين جبريل عليه السلام
through the Trustworthy Spirit, Gabriel, peace be upon him.
النظريه الثامنه
The eighth theory.
ثامنا ربط ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما بين الحروف الف لام راء
Eighthly, Ibn Abbas, may God be pleased with both of them, linked the letters Alif Lam Ra,
والحرفان ح م والحرف نون وخرج من ذلك بالاسم الرحمن
and the two letters Ha Mim, and the letter Nun, and from that derived the name Al-Rahman.
الرحمن
Al-Rahman.
النظريه التاسعه والاخيره اقترح العالم الباكستاني الجليل عبد الله يوسف علي
The ninth and final theory: the esteemed Pakistani scholar Abdullah Yusuf Ali suggested
ان هناك علاقه بين هذه الحروف وبين مخارجها
that there is a relationship between these letters and their points of articulation
عند النطق
when pronounced.
فمثلا الحروف الف لام ميم نجد فيها ان الحرف الف يخرج من عمق من الحلق
For example, in the letters Alif Lam Mim, we find that the letter Alif emerges from deep in the throat,
واللام مخرجها عند طرف اللسان والميم مخرجها عند الشفاه
the Lam's point of articulation is at the tip of the tongue, and the Mim's point of articulation is at the lips.
وكما ذكرت من قبل فان جميع العلماء الاجلاء الذين قاموا بتقديم هذه النظريات والتفسيرات
And as I mentioned before, all the esteemed scholars who presented these theories and interpretations
حول دلاله او معاني الحروف النورانيه
regarding the significance or meanings of the luminous letters
قد اجمعوا على ان تفسيراتهم لا تتعدى كونها تخمينات واستنتاجات لا تستند الى دليل
have agreed that their interpretations do not go beyond being conjectures and deductions that are not based on evidence.
ويجدر بي هنا ان اسجل نظره اهل التحقيق الى هذه الحروف النورانيه
And it is appropriate for me here to record the view of the people of verification regarding these luminous letters,
متمثله فيما قاله الامام الجليل محي الدين بن عربي في كتابه
as represented by what the esteemed Imam Muhyiddin ibn Arabi said in his book.
Muhyiddin ibn Arabi, he was an idol worshiper.
ولضيق الوقت فاني سابدا الحلقه القادمه باذن الله بما قاله الامام ابن عربي عن هذه الحروف النورانيه
And due to time constraints, I will begin the next episode, God willing, with what Imam Ibn Arabi said about these luminous letters.
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
And peace, mercy, and blessings of God be upon you.
صدق الله العظيم
God Almighty has spoken the truth.
الف لام
Alif Lam.
Okay.
I'm going to find out whether there is another continuation of this declaration, which is historical.
Okay, uh, see you later.
This fall, one of the universe's greatest mysteries will be revealed.
A scientific discovery that is epic in its importance, but underestimated to this day.
There is a highly complex mathematical code in the Quran, the ancient book that was written more than a thousand years ago.
The authenticity of which can be verified independently by anyone.
Asselbek Musin in the popular science film, an ordinary miracle.
What is Islam?
Um, what are the sources of Islam?
What are the sources of Islam?
What is Islam?
Burdasen, inshallah.
You'll wear it, God willing.
Nereye?
Where to?
Gidiyorum.
I'm going.